on to say this humiliated reporter who  tried to lie about this bill watched the  exchange governor because i want to ask  you about the recommendation rights in  education what critics call the don't  say gay bill is on the senate floor does  it say that in the bill that you support  does it say that in the bill  i'm asking you to tell me what's in the  bill because you are pushing false  narratives it doesn't matter what  critics say it says it bans classroom  instruction on sexual identity and  gender orientation for who  for for grades pre-k through three i  know you so five-year-old six-year-old  seven-year-olds and um the idea that you  wouldn't be honest about that and tell  people what it actually says it's why  people don't trust people like you  because you peddle false  narratives  they never stop lying do they finally  someone stands up to them